reports of shots fired caused chaos at
the lovers and friends festival last
night the situation turned out to be a
false alarm but several people were hurt
when crowds rushed out of those festival
grounds madison kimbrough spoke with
several people who were there she joins
us live near sahara and las vegas
boulevard with the story tonight madison
authorities say reports of gunfire
happened around 10 p.m we spoke to
people here at the festival grounds
recalling how scary the whole ordeal was
and many still feeling the impact of
last night's stampede
i fell
one time
i just went forward i had no idea what
was happening i just got pushed forward
everybody behind me i just ran as fast
as i could this woman showing us her
bruised up knees after saturday night's
scare at the lovers and friends music
festival when reports of a shooting took
place on festival grounds i was
terrified yeah we saw tlc and we sat
down for a minute in between usher was
going to come on so i saw lights coming
on my girlfriend was sitting behind me i
looked back at her and then all i know
is the crowd just
completely
pushed forward i got trampled like
everybody wouldn't know what was going
on the festival posted this sign just
after 10 p.m that read attention we have
a security incident at the festival
authorities are investigating this sent
concert goers into a frenzy with large
groups of people rushing to leave the
venue somebody yelled gun and everybody
started rushing towards us
and i got trampled to the floor and
pushed aside from my friends
and like i hit my head on the floor but
after investigating metro police
confirmed that there was no evidence of
a shooting this was colson pepler's
first time in vegas celebrating his 21st
birthday but after this incident he says
there's no way he was going for round
two i had tickets for yesterday and
today and i decided that it just wasn't
worth going again because of what
happened yesterday just even though
there was no gun the fear was real three
people were taken to the hospital with
minor injuries
another big talker for people was the
heat now as you're looking at the stage
right now ludicrous is performing but
the heat is to be expected of course a
lot of people saying that there was
water provided a lot of amenities for
people the lovers and friend music
festival concludes tonight reporting
live madison kimbrough live local now